my god
yes I see some game-breaking [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] out of me all right
let's play that [ __ ] god damn it who's
doing that yeah oh you can also move
around with WASD and look around the
table oh that's alright how do you look
at your hand up so you're gonna grab and
like put it in Hey
stop hey you got a thing you can put it
in the front of you put over your name
and I'm not exactly in line I got it
grab it oh I see your hand creeping over
here stay away it's inside the box I
can't [ __ ] cannot all it it's alright
don't each other [ __ ] I can't how do I
says oh you can rotate oh boy [ __ ]
rolling your mouth wait we understand
out of the way way - Jesus - ok ok ok
shut up
everybody stop United States I will
create the Department of hard you flip
it over and you can over enter kick it
out there yeah ah just like in real life
yeah use your brain hole man crying man
my brain will out is secure I'm coming
where's the file
zip it file that's PI ok oh and then I
dragged him out and flip them yes you
could right-click on it even shuffle if
you so desired oh yeah you can mix it up
you can grab them and like shuffle them
like this ah that's so cool
stop cool ok hi everyone I don't care
about the game I resident of the United
States I will create the Department of a
box without hinges key or lid yet golden
treasure inside is hid
ooh [ __ ] we cared Oh I'm president I
will create Department of jerking off
into a pool of children's tears that is
a good boy that's a good department Oh
Mike I will create the Department of
Nazis Oh
did I get the part of children's pool of
Tears
no that wasn't the department name sure
I got it off into a pool of children's
here yeah
all right so does that make me that give
us big ism yeah overhaul more cards if
you guys spit one oh y'all guys where
you're going I put in front of me
see it's not home when it moves around
every fell right now [ __ ] all right
wait hey baby come back to my place and
I'll show you blank
um okay I'm gonna put it out here since
that's like the way Oh God ah I'm always
like so over that I can go for the 12
year old answer or the one I think is
actually like smart really bumpy so all
you put the card out at you got in the
middle yeah why didn't you keep it over
there
the official stack it goes inside this
boxer doesn't count okay all right then
well what if we lose everybody
all right yeah yeah I'm gonna shuffle it
all right just one it's fine yeah
it's just fine that's why I'm shuffling
like crazy good line buddy
Thanks ha ha ha ha ha okay baby come
back to my place and I'll show you I'm
making the feeder ha ha go back to my
place and I'll show you the passage of
time come back to my place is wrong that
one's a loser
Oh real real stink go over there this
one from this one see I never go for
there every one or this one I have an
idea
Nana Nana Nana Nana I gotta go with
making the penis kids yay Oh like that
incense is the penis kisses you can put
it into your hand isn't Saudi everyone
doll I want to show up for everybody
okay
so are these just like free to take oh
oh [ __ ] you could steal things for
people say oh [ __ ] oh my god alright I'm
not saying I'm not I'm not gonna do it
I'm not gonna do it I didn't do it yeah
sure do it
I didn't I actually didn't ok goofy the
screen huh who's got just a pencil
alright anyway Jesus is blank mm-hmm
funny guys ah alright here we go
Jesus is drinking alone that poor mad
Jesus is some douche with an acoustic
bill the imagination oh man oh poor - we
are drinking alone oh sorry
come on Betty this one made me laugh
this is the winner
Oh douche bag we are blue take that
guitar take that [ __ ]
take that remember wind it back Oh booty
go oh I'll make your booty go home baby
to all chance oh my god oh my god lacks
one blank equals so here's how I'm going
to do it you guys just put them like
three in a row somewhere
I'm gonna go stare off into dis here
it's not like I got a solution I got a
solution will do like this
like one two three and joke everyone
keeps to your own area alright okay you
got a draw time remember don't put it
like in front of you so it's obvious who
get more don't forget to draw another
[ __ ] oh yeah we get your draw drew to
start that's right alright ready alright
we're done
oh I got far away from the table
apparently oh where are you
I wish I could like see you like that
this was hard
holy crap okay yeah
and columns not rose no no so each row
is done per speech oh my I'm gonna bawl
on one person okay the wiser was like
three up here because that first card
deck of cards okay I meet the order
usual rain if you were new looking at
people in the pews well I'm sorry I
wasn't watching you guys do all this
okay just flip them over first one
active listening plus intelligent design
equals children on leashes I wasn't I
don't know how we ended up here but I'm
glad we know there's a connection there
I see the cup way it happens
team-building exercises plus wearing an
octopus for a hat equals interspecies
Octodad yep it that Octodad shaft plus
glory holes equals oh and it is children
leashes no I wanted to go Hawk I wanted
to be unpredictable predictable you were
damn come on all shaft foot board
I know why do I get up in the winter
boom I'm gonna pick it what about mine
guys gum bad Rock to Mary looks good
mark gray good man good one thank you
now look thank me a good one good one
man yeah great job thanks guys MTV's new
reality show features eight washed up
celebrities living with come on
hepatitis Reb Schneider their mega yeah
red you got really fast shuffle the [ __ ]
out of these cards my god or something
that's it that's the one that's when he
says oh wait why his hands get so big
what are they feeding in I think your
own hand is tiny the other people kids
oh my mind's all Trumpy to it's okay
MTV's new reality show features eight
washed up celebrities living with the
inability relationship meaningful
meaningful meaningful relationships
sorry
mild autism of God and out break up
small oh my god Oh Oh God yeah man Jesus
okay I know cuz how dare you I always
the first before why'd you pick mild
autism yeah that's a fair question I
feel like damn man well because it was
the most fitting okay yeah maybe
explaining yourself is not going to make
things up because I thought it was funny
oh damn why why would you even say that
I didn't yell way more of a thing which
I wore oh wow [ __ ] I didn't I'll have to
go with the inability to forming in this
relationship me yeah because I finally
win one that's a reality show coupled
with what it is sound hilarious right
I'm all together and then they can't
actually do anything very right tickle
black hard over here finally a service
that delivers blank right your door mm
[Music]
nice talking cars alone everyone leave
my cards alone either my car okay okay
back off man back off man it's wait what
the [ __ ] wait Oh back up
back off it's cool we leave it alone I
said haha broke it I don't know wait how
are you just how are you just fingering
it like that because I'm a goddamn
wizard that's how that's how you're
doing it
how'd you do it because I'm not an idiot
and you click on it you [ __ ] [ __ ]
right clicking opens up my menu which is
the shuffle it's the first oh Christ
ah
anyway would you [ __ ] stuff with you
[ __ ] know how worried it comes back
Oh does it wait
my cards are all different I have to get
on your hand oh well I was the winner
oh wait I'm waiting finally that
delivers Britney Spears at 55 right to
your throw you just hit my card with
your car what the hell yeah yeah I leave
it's a service that delivers full
frontal nudity right to your front door
that our that is a good finally a
service that delivers medieval times
dinner and tournament wanted right to
your front door who's that I want to go
back they give you just half of a
chicken with no you can't I know it's
right it's really fun I've never been I
want to go I hope that's White's card
it was mine hold you my cards are ass
right now you know what screw you guys
I'm getting rid of my hand yeah full
frontal nudity ah yeah that's already a
service you can order a stripper URI
that for known there's no interaction
you know you can't order Britney Spears
55y he literally just shows up at your
door and flashes you and then it walks
away that's it's not a stripper it's
different
hey yeah it's your crazy uncle imagine
if a knight chao stood into your living
room and gave you a chicken to eat
second that sounds like it would be a
horrible horror that won't be pretty
cool be pretty cool
something convenient uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
alright fine man who's winning my
winning by three all right hey you
[ __ ] pig ah ha ha ha ha ha ha and
this is the way the world ends not with
a bang but with up lengths
oh no I threw my card on the [ __ ] it's
up here gets up here hits up here it's
right here it's right here ok
if you drop a card off the edge of the
table it just like falls into the abyss
it's really disconcerting let me try try
it it's run funky gotta hide she's like
my gun look just disappears everybody
know the way the world ends this is the
way the world ends not with a bang but
I got you okay enough chocolate Emma
sure no good here we go this is the way
the world ends not with a bang but with
Stephen Hawking talking dirty I like
that that's good it's so nice
now with the bang but with sneezing
farting and coming at the same time I
like that good that's an experience now
with the bang but ancient Athenian pork
oh why do I think that's wait Socrates
ah man i'ma go with Stephen Hawking
talking dirty yeah God like it's a good
one but I don't want to wait I got one
man yeah Quinn no one cuz my heart yeah
yeah you should have picked an evil
rhymes I got ride Lauri I'm being the
phoniest Oh doc you're not funny at all
not about how funny you are it's about
how you use it it's the motion in the
ocean talking about your hell yeah it's
about good I carried a ruler on Drabek
way tank up a trap
girth it's a trap oh the Donald Trump
seal of approval it's a trap what the
[ __ ] I'm all out of here do not measure
the girth of my sorry your grower not a
shilling see Luke ha ha ha nothing it's
a trap almost giving money to a homeless
person it's a trap I got good to the
homeless yes what oh my god what I'm
with you on that one
yes you guys suck laugh up whoa who
wrote [ __ ] you in green right in the
green hey over there who [ __ ] would
[ __ ] do that man I'm talking about
what's up I clean it up
can you clean up your brain with your
terrible judgment could you do that
Oh that'd be high so maybe if you able
to pick one of my cards one time
well whoa why do you kill ha ha ha just
whoa you go to the cards Bob what are
you doing what it's fine this is fine
all right let's go let's go come on
come on read it let's just read
everything everything's fun Billy Mays
here for blank what this whoa you know I
have a six hell yeah kind of [ __ ]
suction cup nipples are you drawing and
it's not even remotely what I thought
you were drawing this is a butthole in
Helena Patel yeah suppose other holds me
okay everybody shut up and pay attention
huh okay Billy Mays here for crippling
OCD the fact that the OSI is so close
together and you got yelling yells you
got a really illness triggering my OCD
needs its own space well I'm a here for
natural male enhancement is that Jack
you can keep this card thanks man
pulley me here for letting everyone down
he never left okay that's the winner
sit down all right [ __ ] you Wade I'm on
your way a second card
baki we're read it out loud like that
was awesome I don't know let's go this
last round we'll go on oh my god made
him take a thick rack whoever just drew
this ha ha sick box rack wait a
guideline my plan for world domination
begins with right mandible with shuffle
the [ __ ] out of this per second Schultz
ambrosial shuffle shuffle shuffle
that's our thing shuffling that's right
are you a shuffler I plan for world
domination begins with oh [ __ ]
give me one of those [ __ ] Jenny
awkwardly tried to seduce Nathan Fillion
Jenny come on Jenny who's Jenny yeah
yeah I don't know oh I know that I plan
for world domination begins with
unlimited soup salad and bread oh I'm
hungry I'm so good my plan for world
domination begins with pooping as
quietly as possible man I've been there
good why you never been in a situation
where you to poop as quietly as possible
like what non-animal library I go hell
for leather and all I got you're in the
bathroom and someone you know walks in
and you're just like no I got you oh my
god is that a civilian yeah you're like
your ear or they're in the bathroom or
like right off to the liner in the
bathroom in the kitchen yeah yeah and
you're like five feet away Maddie's mom
is cooking dinner right now please think
that's the time when you should poop the
loudest yeah we're in your Adama I'm
here to attend which letter no literally
no yeah Boggs here oh hey are you
discarding my first that's great yeah I
gotta go boobs
I gotta go with pooping as quietly hey
yeah I'm like a jacket art everyone call
bad and I'm great okay sure sure we go
with that mr. Shue Carrie oh hey that's
all I got that one Claddagh cubed
collectively all the combined have the
same number of cards phew and what did
you bring for show and tell
Laura Oh shitty [ __ ] cards against
humanity' cards uh we all ends up don't
stop up all right here we go okay and
what did you bring for a show I got it
ha ha ha ha ha Tech sex toys ah a crappy
little oh not you again
[Music]
oh yeah you're the one who said that
thing about that other thing I'm gonna
judge this based on what I'd be most
impressed at at a show and tell and
that's not impressive Oh
ha not me I like the fixers yeah god
[ __ ] damn it
Oh like you don't have enough cars ready
ha ha ha ha ha I suck
Wade I mean I'm proud of you for
admitting it ha ha
and for what you believe in that's
definitely in prices yeah yeah where you
wrote that upside down way that's pretty
cool yeah your job buddy good job y'all
underline it so everyone can read it
easily wait here's oh there oh this is
the last on the lots are Oh what I won't
win I wonder who's gonna listen okay
yeah I wonder it was very good idea be
like that's right I love a greeting well
you were oh you're right my bad go ahead
huh what does don't one wide in your
Chinese food like that [ __ ] give it here
[Music]
um-hmm open the shitty card I think you
knew how many should have changed it
crappy little new card won't even come
on let us show you like oh I have the
perfect car and I want different card
alright are you doing now in bookstores
the I don't think this is how this works
you sure the boobs are in midair Oh what
don't be white your Chinese food let's
play the first car good yeah that's how
it's post I don't know where it is yeah
yeah what don't you want to fire your
Chinese food wait you did that so I just
stole one of my cards what the [ __ ]
I didn't you talking about oh no it's
back okay I thought I only had six what
what is happening to these boob wait why
are you shuffling so poorly that right
when I take a pink what don't do a
fire-training kun the Hamburglar I would
not want to find that my Chinese like
all of him also big just night I needed
a mass of him what doesn't I fire
Chinese food a bloody presses Oh God
that's correct
that that would be bad idea now nori
it's a me general so what happened to my
baby
oh no yes it's good Wong in general so
what me general so what's what happen
what's is with my Chinese food oh boo
boo hoo hoo like honey boo boo hey it's
okay boo-boo my chicken has a boo-boo
I think of all of these I don't wanna
put the bloody past yeah yeah see I
thought I had to go but you just steal
two of them you saw three of my
character no I had one I [ __ ] had one
don't you steal my card just throwing
off the sighs I had fight card maker
three I don't think so I don't recall
you having them yeah I don't recall
either last play yeah yeah any card yeah
because this is golf yeah bad one he had
the lowest yeah game everybody born
I agree Bob won Bob won I wrote that in
my notebook I did I was like you know
what rules you know what Bob wins check
it out check it out you could see it in
the notebook wait wait no hang on wait
I'll quick spray wait Bob that's one Bob
oh you fix it what is this over here
supposed to be a penis
[Music]